foreign
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of
Fight Night flashbacks I'm here with the
MMA genius the mad scientist of calling
fights I've lost a ton of money to them
it is my brother from a very old mother
Brian Callan Brian Callan thanks what's
up buddy thanks for doing this great to
see you you should be running this show
thanks man I just lost two Grandy on a
bet with uh freaking Market of Charles
Oliveira I've got some good sources I
can solve good sources so true at the
end of the day today's gonna be a little
different because it it it touches that
MMA world but the crossover fight you
got the the YouTuber that's the casuals
calling the YouTuber Jake Paul versus
Anderson Silva this Saturday right 7 P.M
on Showtime we'll have a cow bass fight
campaign for it yeah
um we're gonna start off I'm gonna show
you some highlights yeah of the the one
of the greatest ever do it Anderson
Silva yeah and we have one boxing match
of his in here with the Julio uh Cesar
Chavez Jr yeah but I just want to
refresh your memory please before you
give us the breakdown this fight
I know the Chris leaving thing now this
was Anderson was first fright he he was
going to retire yeah and then he comes
to the UFC this is his kind of coming
out party and this is Chris
you know that what is that thing that uh
Bobby big that Bobby the the thing the
bobblehead yeah that's that was the
inspiration he's got that kind of a face
just a chiseled strong Diamond Head now
how crazy is this Anderson Silva in
Pride right he was good in Pride but he
wasn't the spider and pride he was going
to basically retire in big nog he was
like no just give it a second go but he
was he was done he's done and big no he
was like come on man you got to do this
you're a special you know skill here you
got special talent and he's the one who
talked him into coming over to the UFC
so before Chris leaving at the time we
weren't aware of how good spider was hit
it Chris Steven was fighting a phantom
you may as well try to catch yeah
this is a Hard Rock Hotel and they you
know this is where the infamous this is
where his speed was stupid tough one
fight was held Forest Stefan there's a
young big John everybody's getting older
man now uh leaving here is the perfect
dance partner because he could take a
shot and boy did his head take shot look
at look at the speed and look at him was
a big name too he's coming off The
Ultimate Fighter he's a fan favorite
toughest [ __ ] just look at Anderson move
dude yeah look at the speed
by the way that he's moving like a boxer
true or false yeah I mean shots you know
the difference between him and leaving
here he's not really he was not a lot
not a lot of head movement no but he's
coming
Anderson was very good at staying out of
range and just his time insane look at
this yeah it's not a good time it's not
a good day this one fans like who is
this bald Brazilian just mopping the
floor with Chris leaving because because
oh my God Chris is not
that's not a good thing I mean just a
Molly [ __ ] here yeah that's how fans we
introduced to Amsterdam Silva yeah
there's toss checks cash check one of
the best American wrestlers look at him
dancing having a good time
a lot of people forget how good Anson
was I don't know I don't to me the top
three to ever do it in his prime 100 he
was the top three to ever do it and he
was the first guy to be like the Matrix
he was the first guy to show what
striking could really be against guys
who who weren't Strikers but wrestlers
it was a whole different thing now
remember not yet but look at him just
piecing him up here I mean oh my God
just no step back was just walking
forward he just didn't he was just
trying to land something Lefty and then
just got lit up like you didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on
you can't find a sparring partner like
Anderson Silva I don't know if you know
that even if he could even if it matters
it doesn't matter you're gonna get hurt
and sparring you're not gonna be able to
make the fight well remember Amazon was
so damn good at boxing in his prime and
kind of Roy Jones Jr Prime right out of
Roy Jones Prime but remember there's a
ton of talking I'm pretty sure
contractors signed for instance Silva
versus Roy Jones Jr then Dana back then
was in his open minded as is now put the
kibosh on it that's how good he was yeah
Roy Jones
different animal even even past his
prime be a tough yeah it's different
kind of thing hit very hard now this
um I believe is see now I talked to
Forrest Griffin I said well I think it
was Forrest and I said what was it he
said his ability his eye his ability to
measure distance and just be on the edge
of the pocket just right at the edge and
I know you've been around for as far as
a giant man bigger than I am he's bigger
than you are way bigger what cuts the
light heavy weight just a crazy stuff as
they come but yes there's also a change
of guard here where the size really
didn't matter when Kim Nelson silver
because even though force was the bigger
more stronger guy he was slower didn't
have as much technique and just see
these guys it's literally like that he's
fighting and fighting the spider at the
Pinnacle dude like it was probably the
best time of his life like if you ever
found a place where he was the greatest
it was this when you think of him when I
think of him for forest and he's doing
this [ __ ] oh that's what I think about
nuts hit it his head movement
and Forest was probably like ah this is
going to be weird I don't know
kickboxer please kickboxing was a Savage
light heavyweight like you should have
been heavyweight giant but again speed
skill but again force was another
another guy we're like you would say did
anything great besides his demeanor like
he was a Savage you know Hall of Famer
clearly because the ultimate fighter won
had a good career yeah but Anderson
civil is just
probably couldn't solve it is he a legit
six three yeah yeah so and look at the
way he flows and you know yeah
now now he's just watching he's just
downloading he's downloading moving I
see what you're doing you're Pawn with
your jab you're trying to get distance
with your jab I got you but notice he
baits guys in so if and you he's had
some fights like the Maya fight you know
some of the tallies ladies fight see
where his eyes don't engage you can get
a little you know lackadaisical yep but
notice force and Chris Lieberman are
guys that come forward and then we come
forward on the spider not a good idea
bad idea now now look at him he's
watching us he's watching his uh his
shoulders looking at his movement all
right I see what you're doing Forrest
just got caught there he's like maybe I
won't kick anymore I'm gonna do some
more kicking I'll kick inside tree
trunks too yeah he does I want to do
Superman I'll think of Superman punch
here that didn't all right also I would
say when he was like just dominating
when he come out to DMX yeah and the
lights would go black best walk out of
all time a whole different thing very
similar Mike Tyson wouldn't come out
yeah
his distance control which is what makes
him you know for this Jake Paul fight
you know I know Jake Paul is younger
more explosive but distance even though
box Marines can be you know smaller but
distances everything tough to get up his
ability he's on the pocket look at him
slipping this slip moving
he's moving and he's slipping this
knowing his knees and yeah kicks look I
mean
for now now he knows now he's like well
once he gets the timing down force is
laughing which I don't know why yeah
well because you're like ah damn it this
is a video game he's going you are that
guy now now Anderson's like how about I
press let me I'm gonna go now I'll go a
little let's see oh you missed my head
straight coming in yeah once they start
lunging they just get oh no you can't
kick me now I'm he's shrugging now he's
just playing around now I got now he's
in your head now I'm in your head uh oh
uh-oh now Forrest goes hey he's stronger
than I thought he just love to the
Anderson now Anderson's in a fight come
on come get it let's talk like he'll sit
in the pocket there was his head he'll
just move his head
I'll keep my hands down and I'm gonna
take oh I'm too fast for you and as far
as keeping his hands up like a good
boxer oh that's so stupid
I mean God that's stupid one of the
greatest knockdowns of all time that
your senior will our boy are Corona's
the Fantastic photography I've seen the
picture of him and Anderson since taking
off the Spider-Man mask yes I have it's
fantastic Eric Williams is a great
photographer look at him he's helping
him up oh he's the nicest guy oh he just
held him up and said here here I got you
that's a mind [ __ ]
as far as pressing forward at least
catching shots nothing about Forest good
job as they come dude yeah great all
right uppercut dipping to the left check
hook there I mean a little Hook is just
on the jab hook look at his hands down
boom Oh no I just threw I threw a right
left I don't want to fight anymore how
about that
yeah it's just a different level yeah
it's just a freak just absolute freak
from slipping the jet of the jab the all
the Combos and then Landing dropping
them and then Force rushes in and stuffs
that he just knew he was outclassed top
y'all must have forgot people forget how
good Anderson was man no
no
yeah
yeah and and you get
you get trained so hard every Victory he
could taste it's it's like people think
it comes easy but that guy trained I
know guys who trained with him and they
said he was just a martial arts nerve
and a nerd and never stopped training he
was always trained exactly think about
how close chelseona was to beat him I
know literally two minutes away I know
what was winning the fight
triangle and he got cut in the Triangle
but you're fighting a champion you're
fighting one of the best to ever do this
oh no you can't boom I'm gonna hit you
as I'm moving back that's even a hard
shots more forces giant ass Mass coming
forward that's kind of what that's how
uh verdum got knocked out yeah bye yep
rushing in yep but again this is
work yeah oh you're talking about that
your weights on your front foot your
ears hands are down no I'm saying forest
was was throwing like this and he was
his weight was not he just said I'm
gonna go For Broke [ __ ] this yeah it's
like desperation like that's not the
technique's weird not not great boom Oh
that's not fun that's
that's a step I mean so as far as
highlights go in the Hamptons I mean he
just didn't want to do it anymore for us
to his credit was like that time he that
time he did yeah that time he did
I remember the greatest knockout I've
ever seen was uh uh when he knocked out
um Vitor Belfor I had front row seats my
agent my manager lets me man sitting
next to me remember Lex had bad eyes at
the time yeah Anderson Frank cakes I
remember he had bad eyes because he
borrowed my car yeah yeah I told you not
do that he kept so I'm here I'm in the
front row doing UFC promo they gave me
front row tickets yeah my manager I I
want to bring a bunch more people he's
like I'd love to go man
The Knockout happens like what's the
best knockout I've ever seen he was well
I can't even see what happened I'm like
Oh no you're telling me that's hilarious
you're telling me you asked for a ticket
and you can't see now this was Vitor
where I don't think he was allowed to do
a whole lot of uh ah he's still dabbling
in it Daddy okay because this is no punk
Vito either he looks rather soft there
let's take a little break from Fight
Night flashback with my brother Brian
Callan we're talking Jake Paul Anderson
Silva this Saturday it's going down but
I'll tell you what's not going down is
your safety and that cyber protection
you're gonna need it my friends at a
vast one is a global leader in cyber
protection for more than 30 years
trusted by over 435 million users
prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every month all right a
vast new all-in-one solution Avast one
helps you take control of your safety
and privacy online through a range of
features all right because Avast
believes the central protection should
be available to everyone not just the
fancy rich people out there no way a
free version of vast one still includes
award-winning free AV free VPN free 5
Iowa and much much more we got you a
vast privacy features keep your identity
and actions hidden that's why vpns are
so important because if you're at a
coffee shop you're doing work at a
public place a library the airport who's
at a library but the airport coffee
shops you don't want people stealing
your identity you don't want people
knowing where you're at that's where a
VPN helps you out there they have
anti-virus award-winning antivirus that
stops viruses and malware from harming
your devices all right that firewall
protection keeps personal information
secure and prevents attacks that seek
access of your computers and they steal
it and use your data we don't want that
man we got you so again I use Avast one
on all my stuff because I'm always
online I got my laptop I'm doing my
thing all right thanks to Avast for
supporting Fight Night flashbacks Jake
Paul Anderson Silva conflict take
control of your online world all right
with a vast one that helps you stay safe
from viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crimes
learn more about Avast one at avast.com
this app episode of Fight Night
flashbacks for Jake Paul Anderson Silva
is brought to you by the best Kratom on
the freaking planet you can't trust any
Kratom you don't know who to trust
you're like man maybe I don't like pills
maybe I don't like powder I don't know
what to do well my friends at happy
hippo they make the best Kratom and also
they make it a variety of ways what do
you like pills gummies powder shots yeah
they have these super high concentrated
Kratom shots the pink lemonade it comes
in this cool little pink bottle has a
cute little hippo on it right a happy
hip about that he's smiling at you you
want to drink it before I do any shows
any podcast stand up whatever it is
working out I'm using happy hippo that's
my only crate of my trust the best
focused product I've ever used and all
you got to do is visit happyhippo.com
use promo code thick boy you get 20 off
for life you can use that code as many
times you want share it with your
friends your family your aunts your gay
uncles your cousins whoever your hipster
freaking buddy out there your emo sister
they all can get it happy hippo the best
Kratom on the planet happyhippo.com
promo code thick boy 20 off for life
in comparison to what he could usually
look like he looks like yeah but he's
still he's still a Savage yeah you mess
with your endocrine system though and
things so people will always say like go
on National and fly Brazilians he took
it easy I'm like you ever seen the Vitor
Belfort fight yeah
he's I mean just disrespectful dude just
five toes in the mouth yeah top five
dozen and you know who taught he did
because he went to a very secret
underground area and trained with the
guy named Steven Segal
well yes yeah who taught him the artist
now did you see he seems to go at the
UFC he did see him there he doesn't look
like he's been missing any meals we
reached out we want to be the first uh
athlete endorsed by thick boy we want
him as the thick boy Captain there's
nothing wrong with that he uh the
demands he's making is insane though is
that true insane yeah well let him do
his thing
he wants to be we want some more
children Rush uh I told him we can't
right now got it got it yeah he's is he
a Russian citizen yes yes okay Maryland
you and uh Rogan thought he was fighting
the Russian military yes
yeah he's um I remember people were Boon
in this fight like come on do something
because rather feeling each other out
because they're both like speed freaks
like come on everybody here it is here
he goes here we go that left see the
back leg cocked up yeah like a spider
here we go I can see your Chin's like
all right I got the hand I got the hand
opening I see an opening there's a lot
of respect let me relax a lot of
respects a lot of respect respect Vito's
hands are crazy now don't kid yourself
you don't want a box hands in the west
you got some issues have you tried a box
with Vitor Dynamite Kid yep
Lincoln Vito is just waiting man
and fans are booing yeah that's why I
feel like I don't want to [ __ ] around oh
boy I remember doing that with his hand
yeah
yeah I was there as a Young Man front
row with my age is that right who
couldn't see
there you go buddy here it goes look at
his land look at his arms he's doing
that confuse him he's like all right see
what you're doing you got to pick your
spot you might get just one shot he's
loading up that skinny back leg there
yeah look how thin his legs are yeah
very thin very very speedy
a lot of speed here we can't volume but
oh then there goes all right
it's coming up here
we keep saying that but I promise it's
coming up here a lot of bouncing around
a lot and trust me they call this the
feel outside dude people were bullying
front foot roundhouse kick front foot
roundhouse kick here we are here we are
in the clinch scramble to the top
okay see I remember doing that with his
hands
now I want to ask you a very very honest
question yeah was I Boon yeah no if now
Anderson's of as great as he is right
now you put him in there with Izzy out
of Sanya well they fought right yeah but
I mean oh
that's fast
okay that's very fast
that was crazy fast nuts oh that's fast
that's the doorbell for
ridiculous knockout all right that was a
fast one and right now I'm like oh my
God it's the craziest thing I've ever
seen my manager which wait what happened
I can't sue oh boy he's staring at them
yeah I was like can you use the ticket
dude you know how many people want to
sit here that's tough that's a tough
that's a tough knockout wow that's your
job one of the best that's your job that
that's probably the best front kick
knockout all the time or Leo Machida
Randy Couture well Randy Couture lost
teeth in that one yes and I helped Randy
get ready for that fight did you yeah I
did but I don't throw front kicks like
that so we oh my God yeah that's what
the ball you're for your foot it's not
going to be a fun time yeah there you go
you lost all your
yeah just the way I rehearsed it just
the way we rehearsed to be top five
that's where Taekwondo comes in guys and
I've always said if you don't have
taekwondo you're probably not going to
be a champion
there it is
in my heart because he went home to his
wife you ever seen his wife I sure have
still winning
still winning there's Randy Couture
right there
oh yeah cause he trained in Vegas for
that fight there it is
who did yeah did he talked about his
camp out there yeah and me and Nate Mark
cart and GSP went to go train with him
you know what the maybe I'm the common
denominator here because I was helping
Vitor for that he gets front kicked yeah
I'm helping Randy he gets bad luck you
curse
now once because listen Anson this is
where I want to watch like this is he's
like me throwing any kicks no knees how
long ago is this by the way
uh January June 20 20 21. okay I said 22
many times this is an idea of what we're
gonna get now look at this look at this
look at this his movement though yeah
look at this movement and his speed
he's got some speed guys now even though
now people go you know Hulu Cesar Chavez
barely trained for this is like still
fine still fighting the guys from boxing
his whole life okay and he was a former
woman now Julio Cesar Chavez about the
seventh round I was like oh I better get
going here man six roundies I'm I'm
losing rounds yeah
these are just highlights but I want you
to see because you see how you see his
defense did you see you see the shoulder
roll that Anderson did so the that's
he's thrown I'll peek of the distance
right now yes like look at his distance
he's not really taking hits Now watch
how hard he is to hit you see that you
see how he's off the center line every
time he throws
look at that
look at that pop pop see I think as far
as fundamentals go as far as straight
boxing goes Anderson's gonna have the
upper hand on Jake 100 but as far as
speed power goes like I said Amazon's
not really a knockout now I'm boxing at
his age yeah but if you know if you're
trading shots of Jake Paul that's that's
where this gets it's important what I'm
watching here is that Julio Cesar Chavez
has not landed a clean glove he's
rolling he's catching shots he's look at
this he's stepping to the side
really good see that little fake with
his foot yeah it still makes sense but
well we worked on that too yep we worked
on that too but we were we were very
ready for this fight now look at this
I'll stand right there I'll stand right
in your grill I'm gonna look at you I'm
gonna bend my knees now take your shots
go ahead I'll stand right here let me
Rope A Dope for a second but look at
Hulu service
trying to get to work there look at
answers get to work get to work I'll
stand here I'll push you back and I'll
motion to you back that's
that that oh look at that he got hit
there yeah but he's still he still gets
angry he's just chilling there
don't start throwing he's trying to get
him going he's like come on Wow his dad
must have been so pissed off by the way
oh how pissed was his team I told you oh
uppercut you see that
Canelo before he hugged his son I don't
think his son was Kate's side a ringside
he's doing that cool thing with his foot
you see what he's doing he's like like
throwing his foot up and you're like oh
what is that movement let's take another
little break from Fight Night flashbacks
with my boy Brian count we breaking down
Jake Paul Anderson Silva now if you're
gonna watch this and you're all excited
about It's on Showtime you're excited to
watch the combats fight at 7 pm live on
thick boy and you're like man I'm so
excited for the weekend but the promise
I can't focus I don't know how to get in
the zone I get so much work going on I
can't get in that freaking The Zone I've
been there before I don't know how to
get back there what if I told you there
are two little pills two nootropics but
not just any nootropics there's a lot of
nootropics out there I'm talking about
award-winning proven no Tropics for my
friend dead on it if you go to on it.com
right you go to onnit.com you go to
onnit.com
chab you save 10 off the best nootropics
to ever touch your mouth that's right
you can use that promo code to help your
boy out on it.com shop or you can go to
Walmart and pick up some Alpha Brain but
you don't want to go to Walmart you want
to help your boy out and go to audit.com
and you get the best nootropics on the
planet my boy Joe Rogan swears by it
he's the one that launched it into a
different Stratosphere of sales because
he says he uses it for every podcast it
helps inform better sentences I need to
talk more like Joe Rogan he's so much
smarter so this is the closest thing I
can do to use his freaking brain
vocabulary I swear by Alpha Brain and on
it's so positive that you're gonna love
it if you don't money back guarantee
give them two weeks tell him I don't
like it no return necessary keep the
bottle but you're gonna love it the best
nootropics on the planet and you can
save all 10 off the on it website the
workout gear the freaking elk bars their
creatine their delicious protein their
fish oils they're multivitamin they're
kettlebells their steel Club Macy's save
10 South by going to onit.com shop 10
off everything but also 10 South Alpha
Brain you're welcome now let's get back
to the program
yeah look at this he looks very good
yeah dude come on
yeah of course my money's on I have to
put my money on you know who OH Anderson
so I mean it makes sense
you have to go I know you have to go
with Jake and I appreciate you I respect
your friendship I like that you're there
for your boy and if Jake beats him I'm
gonna be give some respect I already
have respect for him but I'm going to be
a lot more right yeah yeah it's not like
llama fact this engine doesn't look like
weather well he looks young sir he looks
young
he looks like a young boxer [ __ ] if
Julio Cesar Chavez barely trained for
this he's getting out classed in Boston
100 years
Landing a glove on Anderson no the
distance
dipping to the left and throwing this
but notice how you angled out too look
at this yep
yeah that's a pain in the ass to deal
with
that yeah so if you're an Amsterdam fan
you got to think as far as boxing goes
Anderson's going to be the more
technical boxer yeah cardio wise goes if
it goes past six rounds Anderson has
experience going past six rounds so
you'd give the experience and cardio
Advantage answering Silva the only
caveat you got age you got age you got
age but the only caveat there is because
Jake is an explosive fighter he hasn't
done you know the rounds like the
championship rounds or even gone past
[ __ ] what six rounds so it's like
you know there's some there's some
doubts if you're putting money on Jake
Paul here correct but correct he does
have that knockout look at how he's
standing there look at how he
understands where
is he where his his just really hard to
hit you can't catch him at 47 years old
or whatever he is you're still not
putting a glove on him and you've been
boxing your whole life and Julio's
trying to throw combos too wow now I
would not look at his dad said Jake's
getting here give him a thumbs up his
dad's give us thumbs down
um I do think Jake's gonna give him more
Fritz as far as Jake's gonna be a little
quicker a little faster he's young right
Split Decision how do you and that's in
Mexico that's in Mexico crooked judgment
boxing is a Mexican that's a big deal
Split Decision that's a big win but they
were mad at him the Box Community
doesn't care like uh he barely trained
for that that's the main thing he didn't
look you know he over looked Anderson's
like all right still got beat up yeah
and it's a good answer yeah and stayed
out of getting out of danger now before
he kind of made your pick he said he
can't bet against uh the spider but
can I show you some Jake highlights love
to see it I've seen it all but I'd like
to see it again hit it now this is when
he was a very novices very novel this is
the first one boom yeah see but the
thing here is if you're a jake fan the
the thing that makes you happy is it's
timing which you can't really teach here
boom
down behind the area he's strong
powerful young right got him he doesn't
have many miles as Anderson does now
Nate can't fight with [ __ ] right so
we're not we're not putting too much
into this because if now for the dunking
contest I got Nate all day yeah but this
isn't this is boxing and he gets
absolutely starched yeah and became a
meme and probably not worth the money
for him and it was exhausting so yeah
wait wait both of them notice how their
weights both both their weights are on
their front foot there's a lot of
there's a lot of leaning in your your
head is over your your front foot that's
why they're constantly like this like
none of the punches are landing at the
end yeah he hasn't grooved his stance
yet his weight's off not but see how
he's gonna be remember this version of
Jake and as we move forward when we end
up Woodly remember what wait do you see
his footwork and movement in the get a
little better get a little better the
heart one of the hardest things to
master might be boxing but yeah the
sweet science yeah
so you know right now you can see that
they're both going to the same pattern
he's dipping his head and throwing that
overhand right dipping his head throwing
that overhand right see all I remember
though is The Knockout that's what
people play but watch his right hands oh
you see they did
same exact move and that's fine it
worked and most people thought they
should have stopped it here and bringing
it over like that that sort of Duran
thing Nate Robinson's tough that is
tough I mean but I
I should be comparing them to Durant
it's a tough it's tough one
you're right I apologize for that one
anybody very very many tap is
well okay sir yeah he got back up Nate's
tough look at how tough Nate is though
oh see that that was the one that yeah
at least became a meme he's all sleeping
that was tough that was very tough not
to throw salt on you when they bring up
a Jake Paul music video yeah that's
tough going to Slit your throat that's
how you get really hurt
yeah I mean you know but you forget that
that fight they're both an experience
and like rushing in yeah we talked about
that let me see the Jake Paul Tavern in
Woodley please
they've been asking no we don't have to
watch that because it starts yeah Ben
didn't even Ben was like what yeah
yeah you're gonna let them look how
packed that place is the most from Jake
in this fight because he's he's had
longer to train right and he's gonna
make Leaps and Bounds improvements he
also has electric electric chairs
there's that there's still there's said
head button Nate's very Nate's a sturdy
kid just a sturdy Germanic
dude with a real work ethic boom
see what I mean all right so there's
see that that could be problem with
Anderson that's correct answer is not
that explosive like he was you know so
it was upsets
combos it's just combos again he's gonna
have more technique than both these guys
put together but he hits you he hits you
I do think Jake is gonna get down on the
scorecards the first time where he might
go [ __ ] Jake's down whatever three
rounds and then I think he catch some
wobbles him with something right that's
what that's how I see the fight going
but you know it's in it's freaking
absence I don't know how much Tyron
would leave and wants to fight you know
this is but he
but but you can't say that William's not
giving a damn good shot here hell yeah
there's nowhere
look at Jake's even distance control
here compared to the first fight you
watched like yeah he looks like circling
circling around moving to his jab hand
now standing there just outside just on
the at the edge of the pocket
good movement good movement see how his
weight's way better now he's like he's
he's he's way more centered
he moves better he's moving in and out
yeah
yeah
but good cardio you think Jake's didn't
get behind in the score cards early on I
think you know it's gonna be tough to
get him around between in the first four
I look at patterns I look at like how
much diversity he has in his in his
movement and patterns and and because
Anderson will download you right quick
if you're just going low if you're like
jabbing to the body and coming over the
top he's gonna see that real quick
answer usually takes a round or two
before you know moves around so yeah but
even in in that I do you know maybe if
Anderson is down low because he doesn't
want to get clipped early on Jake could
win a few of those rounds but if
Anderson's on pressuring him and trying
to get Jake flustered and wear them out
and rack up some rounds probably but I'm
seeing Jake what I see with Jake is he
puts his head down and he he just
Barrels in like he's still doing a lot
of that he's putting it's just going up
and using his strength against a smaller
man and that that's going to be trouble
if you try that with the Anderson Silva
yeah I'm certainly capitalize on that
he's gonna take advantage of that you're
going to see these things it's going to
be easy to see oh you're about to do
that this time you're doing the same
thing that time so it's a question of
what he comes with can he change his
game up you see what I mean combo there
by Woodley yeah can we talk about Jake's
electric short
those are electric those are fantastic
aren't they cool yeah those are
fantastic and I like that you picked
that up because you love fashion I
didn't even see that no that's
impressive thank you sir that's pretty
impressive yeah see what I mean though
you see that exchange right there and
that that's getting tall that's just not
ex that it takes a while oh there you go
there you go see and that that's the
thing about Jake he did one he went like
this he dipped tyron's hands came down
right over the top boom and came over
the top so his body dipped and then he
threw well remember remember you're
saying he he kept blowing his head
dipping then they would engage in the
close distance but that's what opened up
the knockout shot so again for Anderson
he might be able to pick that up stuff
like that but all Jake needs is that one
opening and he's you're flat in your
face now and Anderson has some miles on
him a lot of guys have tried that with
Anderson he's not gonna be in that
distance probably my guess is he will
also eventually he will but a lot of
guys did that's a that's a that's a
basic pattern dip I get you to bring
your hands down because if you're Jake's
coaches you're not gonna say hey here's
the move we're gonna sit on the outside
and pick him apart that ain't happening
yeah you don't have the skill set in
order to do that and pick out an
instance so it's not happening you have
to close the distance get dirty land
some shots in the inside and then
hopefully he you know makes a mistake
and you open up and knock him out yeah
but if you're then there's no way that's
their game plan if their game plan is to
sit on the outside and try to win rounds
yeah you're [ __ ] you're gonna lose
eight to zero yeah it's not happening
you're not you're not out pointing
Anderson Silva no he's one of the you
know one of the greatest Strikers we've
ever had and because of his distance
control so Jake has his workout you know
cut out for him but also Jake rushing in
on a guy like Anderson like again I know
it's MMA but with Force Griffin Chris
lieben you know all these guys that
Russian oh my God all those guys that
rushed in that's what opens them up and
Anson knows that he's gonna capitalize
on that yeah I just don't know if Anson
has a power at his age what is he 45 now
to knock it 47 47 anaka Young Buck out
like Jake Paul I think Jake Paul can eat
some of those shots and still land the
big one
if I'm better that's what you're hoping
for but who knows yeah it's a bad
knockout it's interesting though right
yes you're gonna watch it you're looking
forward I can't wait to remember your
eye Hall Le'Veon Bell is there I sold
you on your right hall I can't wait
look at that look at that that that's a
nice [ __ ] that's a right hook Savage
we found that with only like four fights
history it's pretty impressive I agree
no matter who it is I agree especially
if it's Woodley he's a Hall of Famer
yeah so Kudos Jake Paul has his work cut
out for him I think you can get it done
there's this girl again he's still
winning so I think he's well he he won
everything at that point that's that's
his girl
this one in life yeah he's one on
YouTube he makes you stand very well
than we do in seven years so the thing
is is he's doing well right he's got
octopuses and snakes and Hand Grenades
tattooed to his body no sense makes no
sense and it doesn't have to and it
doesn't have to he's doing that tongue
thing right now he's winning and there's
his there's his mom's mom
she's a good woman yep so he has a hard
time with that it's an interesting fight
regardless you're you're you you say
it's hard to pick against Anderson which
every
cell my body agrees with you but I have
to go with Jake I know you do his Youth
and his explosiveness I think he might
find a way to get done if it goes
decisions probably definitely gonna be
uh Spider yeah so and I appreciate that
yeah I appreciate it I appreciate that I
think that we are going to see now what
Jake's actually made of I don't think
Jake with all due respect has actually
been tested me neither but I also think
to your to your point uh we're gonna see
what Jake's made of even if Jake were to
lose answer and Silva by decision but he
can like look good doing it like if he
doesn't get out class
where it's like a split decision or even
if it's a majority decision but Jake's
had him hurt in some spots and he still
loses I think he does more for Jake's
career than if he were to beat you know
a Tommy Fury or the Hassan Rockman
Junior like that stuff's whatever this I
think he's gonna get approval that he's
kind of been looking for from some of
the MMA families not all of them they're
never he could knock out canal and
people like that's an old Canal it's
never gonna work for him but I think
this could give him the best shot at
getting improve well when uh who I'd
like to know who his training partners
are and also who actually trains him
he's got good training Great Train
trainers yeah they're great right I
think Costa Rica or that Puerto Vallarta
or whatever those guys those guys are
teaching him well yeah he's doing his
thing but uh if you enjoyed this it's
just a little snippet of what's coming
this Saturday you can watch the
Calabasas fight companion for Jake Paul
Anderson the Spider Silva first ballot
Hall of Famer UFC Hall of Famer is
putting his his freaking reputation on
the line against a YouTuber named Jake
Paul who's younger with crazy knockout
power that's going down on Showtime 7
P.M Pacific all right you can watch it
live on thinkable YouTube with myself
Frank Mayer Jesse on fire Sam Tripoli
will be thinking of Brian account we
wish you would be in Chicago Chicago
improv see Brian in Chicago I will be I
will be here but next week I'm in San
Antonio week after I'm in Houston get
your tickets thick boy.com baby we love
you thanks for doing this you're the
best can't wait for the fights yeah
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding